hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to four last things
well actually we've got six last deadly
sins to commit before the end of the
game but I gotta start using the items
that I have amongst the various people
now I could probably chisel and mallet
one of these statues can I
the tools are blunt but try anyway you
didn't even give it a shot can i
chiseled and mallet that [ __ ] there
this guy yeah that doesn't need to be
chiseled or melted you never know until
you try alright you want a new loot
hello do you want a drink you want a jam
sure what do you want to play do you
know the witches dance John wands can
she excuse my wrongs anything by Orlando
D'Alessio how about the witches dance
let's do that one
sure do
[Music]
lovely I guess it's very lovely is
wonderful actually
so yeah sure okay alright well oh good
do I have a choice in the matter I I
can't even skip this all right well I
guess we're just committed here okay
we're done you play good for a gutter
pleb Thanks
what happens if I do the other one John
Dallin scan she excuse my wrongs of
course
[Music]
Oh baby that is a sweet something oh
that's good
oh yeah I like that oh yeah oh yeah ah
say it slower that's a good stuff
[Music]
okay well there was no point in that
thank you alright hey do you need a
hammer and chisel dude blacksmith you
need this can you sharpen my chisel
please good man I don't usually work for
free in fact it's kind of disrespectful
for you to even ask what if I ask really
nicely what if I promised a bank what if
I do a sexy dance for you hey pretty
good that what if I do a sexy dance for
you then at least we'll both be
degrading ourselves ha ha okay this is
getting weird alright ask me the chisel
alright hands on fire dude alright well
everybody [ __ ] is fine
alright thanks thank you hey this guy
what do you think of my progress so far
and I guess skedaddle over here can I do
this now use chill it and mallet to
craft stats you have lead in the Swan
mess of yourself expression of inner
turmoil crude copper I gotta go with the
crude copper phallus I'm pretty sure
that's bronze also no no no really
come on alright expression of your inner
turmoil tumultuous Wow why is there an
owl why wait why is their torsos like an
acorn what's coming out of them is that
branches or tentacles or insect legs
what's with the testicle little like any
of that I'm a master sculptor apparently
that okay Lleida and the Swan Oh
beautiful nice boobs I have to censor
that great radiant Oh beautiful fine art
is lovely how about a statue of myself
there's no doubt I deserve a statue for
my work in the field of indolence and
neglect but I have no idea what I look
like the establishments are frequent
don't tend to boast many reflective
surfaces if I'm gonna make a statue
myself I'll need some reference material
[Music]
but I don't know what to do for the loot
hmm maybe if I play a loot for this guy
yeah you want he's clearly a horns guy
I'm not messing with his vibe okay
anybody want to give me some money
anybody want to give me some money for
this amazing Luke work I don't think
they're interested well alright then let
me at least change this so it doesn't
need to constantly be censored air
turmoil alright it's good stuff what
about the rich landowners you think they
would want some they like Loudoun zing
about can I give you some hey buddies
Hey give me money hey dudes get me money
you want to give me money money oh that
is not me playing there I don't think
they're in that was splendid marvelous
effervescent divine okay okay enough you
guys are really the worst hey you gave
this game developer money why can't you
give me some money why is you why this
old man with big nice pig that pig is
really nice and I like the way it looks
and I hope it feels like good company
for you yeah you know what you think
lame-o [ __ ] you man and your pig by you
music is a man-made creation I draw only
inspiration from the work of God how
about you shove your pen right up your
anus gotta be away there's gotta be a
way who's someone appreciate my music
doggy dog please I'm desperate
I need money so badly and if money so so
badly I need it I need it dog oh [ __ ]
I'll pray for you mmm since I lost my
sight my other senses become heightened
I feel every strum of your lute like a
wave breaking over my naked body it
takes all of my strength to remain sane
in the face of this onslaught of
pleasure well that's weird not to drown
in the sea of your music
rad can I have some money for that maybe
give us some money
PI King would you like a serenade will
you get lost in the pleasure of my lute
my pickle fingers will make it real good
for you music is for sissies well you
are just a raging [ __ ] hey can you
stop fighting for one second and
appreciate my art that'd be great
[Music]
alright I'll hammer and chisel the [ __ ]
out of this thing so statue of a fat
dwarf riding a doggy nothing I or anyone
else can do to improve it so I gotta
find there's gotta be a way that I can
get some goddamn coin the only the
people that I know of around here would
be the party goers from the other scene
okay I'm going I'll get there by sharp I
ain't gonna look up a walk through cause
I know cheater I'm gonna get this just
also because it's fast and hitting like
this game is oddly fascinating I just am
in love with the style of it it's bold
choice to be honest it wasn't here again
oh yeah that's right I've been to going
here before I'm a dummy
hello this guy's loitering by the door
app that's what you get for loitering
please don't do that again
it's happening it's your worst nightmare
it's a bunch of slaps it slaps giving up
in here alright hello how you doing what
is this place there's a sheaf Clerk's
office all the town's administrative
paperwork has looked after here who are
you I'm a disreputable looking corner
loiterer you don't look that
disreputable to me well technically I am
employed by the chief clerk but not in
an official capacity alright can you
help me find a document I can but you'll
have to answer my riddle first alright
why do you ask people to answer a riddle
we prioritize intelligent inquiries the
riddle weeds out the imbeciles okay I
will answer it now oh here it is
I'm the one who gave you life but not
your father and not his wife
my powers are great but are not godly I
made your head but not your body Who am
I wah wah that goes down a while nobody
nobody is not the correct answer
can I hear the riddle again grandparents
your grab bars well I am very dumb
apparently I'm one of those imbeciles
hieronymus van hieronymus Van Hema Singh
ah apparently that's not the correct
answer
okay alright good old scribble he's
having a good old scribble please don't
disturb this flirts when they're working
all right excuse it okay hello sort of a
magician he doesn't look very busy his
work involves deep concentration and
mental calm try to figure out how many
of it could possibly matter see he's
trying to figure out how any of it could
possibly matter it probably doesn't but
it seems important somehow so I'm a
double checking my work
he's don't disturb um okay alright then
doodly-doo dude okay hello how you doing
he's engrossed by that document okay
wait who's talking here excuse oh you oh
you okay
arrogant looking at end don't even think
about it I was talking about excuse me
what do you want what is this place
chief Clark's office all the town's
administrative paperwork looked
afterwards here who are you I'm gonna
tendon can you help me find a document
the chief clerk office is very busy
right now
I'm not asking the clerks I'm asking you
I'm very busy right now I have pressing
matters to attend to
yeah it seems like it at the moment I'm
engaged in the task of convincing you to
piss off I won't be free to handle
further inquiries until you piss off so
piss off well that's stupid
Iran amiss boss that was one of the
names that I was gonna list off
Hieronymus Bosch yeah but that wouldn't
be at the Garden of Earthly Delights
this doesn't even make any sense
wait a minute is one of these things
like
pending a man with a strangely familiar
body Hieronymus Bosch are they wait are
these all Hieronymus Bosch wait Jacob
van bootlick wait made your head but not
your body Jacob van Utrecht wait a
minute
strangely familiar your body strangely
familiar head I made your head but not
your body
my power is great but not godly Jacob
van Utrecht you talking about Jacob van
dyck you talking about Jacob and new
Rick you're talking about talking about
Jacob and Rick are we talking about
Jacob a new drink over here we're
talking about Jacob a new trick man how
would I have ever been able to get that
take it back out of here I was think it
was like a logical answer to a riddle
but apparently not
Jacob and Rick yeah this definitely
general knowledge is everyone booty be
able to get it looking for Jacob a new
trick takes a new trick Jacob a new
trick alright okay how about Jacob Jacob
van oh that's not right then each new
trick wait Oh more MORE then you trick a
new trick take the trick
correct what documents are you looking
for copy of the town's official
treachery deceit an extortion regulation
no problem I have that right here I feel
like we could have saved a lot of time
you could just ask me what I want in the
first place but thanks okay cool way to
go
I did it I got something amazing way I
got something okay I got this for you
can I have some money great I'm really
doing all able to squeeze every last
penny out of these saps now these are
cut nice une business with you hey what
did I do
greed yes yes I have yes I
all right oh hell yeah oh hell to the
yeah okay any minute now I get it I get
it I get it okay
there we are oh yeah yeah how much money
do I get no much money well great riches
I've got so many riches I'm gonna go
over to the painter I'm giving some
great riches how many is my great riches
this is just like two pence
these are two pennies this is do pan
easy the way I'm gonna get my painting
yeah paint me would you paint my
portrait now okay take a seat now tell
me what you look like I am a man a man
[Music]
emerging resplendent from a shimmering
lake merging from a lake I have dark
hair and dark eyes dark hair dark eyes
I'm wearing a turkey no I'm wearing a I
am completely nude these are my tasteful
nudes Babu a nude I may be a blind but
I'm a respectable portrait painter I
don't paint smut dang oh come on
fine I'm not naked all right I am a
homunculus a homunculus I'm riding our
horse into battle I have light hair and
dark eyes I am wearing a white dress
yellow cardigan slip-ons may be blind
but I paint from life not from the
imagination
I'm imagine you have described doesn't
have any ring of truth to it okay fine
then god damn of course mmm mr. stickler
for it all right whatever I'm a man I am
sitting on chair right in front of you a
chair dark hair and dark eyes turquoise
jacket I'll see what I can do done oh
hey thanks it's lovely
all right I just learned that I'm
hideously ugly but I know what to do
with this now for summaries
I'm gonna get my vanity on I think
that's probably what it is something
like that vanity maybe I don't know
there we go oh I've got a ugly worth
okay pop this bad boy on their craft
tattoo myself there's no doubt I deserve
a statue for my own work in the field of
indolence and neglect but I have no idea
what I look like oh well I have it I
have it oh there we go now I have some
reference material okay all right here
we go of me make you love me oh yeah
marvelous oh god yeah yes yes yes yes
yes pride yes oh yes yes I'm beautiful
you guys are seven look at me and just
go like man that guy he knows how to put
his face together and that's all I am
every day looking at myself I'm goddamn
gorgeous all right so anyway I got two
more deadly sins and I bet the next two
sins are gonna cap lapis clap okay
they're gonna come so easily so thank
you everybody so much for watching I'm
gonna continue playing this game it's
super fun and let me know what you think
down the comments below and as always I
will see you in the next video bye